Yesterday, Joe Biden officially secured 270
electoral votes as all 50 states had their
electors formally cast their ballots.
So, yes, this is the end, except it already
was the end before.
And anyway, the Trump cultists are still coming
up with new ideas and again, moving the goalposts,
which we will get to.
But for those of you who like me, prefer to
live in reality, you may recall that on November
3rd, the people voted in their states in a
state election which would determine which
electors would vote on December 14th, which
was yesterday in the states where Joe Biden
got more votes on November 3rd, Democratic
electors cast electoral votes for Joe Biden
in states where Donald Trump got more votes
on November 3rd, Republican electors cast
electoral votes for Donald Trump.
Joe Biden was expected to receive three hundred
and six electoral votes based on the results
from November 3rd.
And indeed he did without a single faithless
elector based on the order in which states
voted California shortly after 5:00 p.m. Eastern
cast its 55 electoral votes for Joe Biden,
that officially put Joe Biden over 270.
So let's look at that for a moment from the
California state House yesterday.
I will now announce the tally of the vote
for the office of president of the United
States.
For Joseph R. Biden of Delaware, a Democrat,
eyes 55, nose zero.
And with that, Joe Biden now officially the
president elect, now remember on Saturday,
November 7th, I believe it was, numerous media
outlets started calling Joe Biden the president
elect.
They called the election for Joe Biden that
night.
Joe Biden addressing the nation.
And people like Donald Trump and others said
the media does not get to call the election
in any official sense and the media doesn't
decide who is president elect.
Now, that was true then.
It was also true in 2016.
But in 2016, Donald Trump was glad to accept
the media's call.
But now it is not the media, it is the electors
that have voted.
So is this it?
Well, Trump is saying no, because they still
have January 6th, January 6th.
What happens then?
On January six, the House and Senate hold
a joint session to count the electoral votes.
And Mike Pence will oversee that as Vice President.
Al Gore oversaw that in the year 2000 when
he was defeated by George W. Bush.
And Mike Pence will oversee it on January
6th as he has been defeated as well.
So the new goal post this is the point, the
new goalpost is that on January 6th, Republicans
in the House and Senate during that joint
session of Congress to count electoral votes
are going to have objections ready to go.
It's likely that when Georgia when Georgia's
turn comes to say, we give our votes to Joe
Biden or Pennsylvania, you will see a Republican
members of the House and or Senate stand and
object.
And Mike Pence will say, for what reason does
the gentle lady from Texas rise today or whatever?
And they will have some objection.
And the goal of that part of the trumpet is
to prevent this from actually happening on
January 6th.
Now, it's going to happen that this is what's
going to happen on January 6th.
You can already imagine the triggering and
Donald Trump absolutely losing his mind yesterday
as Joe Biden won the Electoral College.
Later in the evening, Joe Biden addressing
the nation and Trump just tweeting and retweeting
nonsense for hours, posting debunked, baseless
election conspiracy theory after theory with
apparently no understanding or sense whatsoever
that he's embarrassing not only himself, but
the country.
Some example tweets.
I can't post them all.
I like you too much to post all of them, to
show you all of them.
But some example, tweets from Trump include
Dominion Voting machines are a disaster all
over the country.
Change the results of a landslide election.
Can't let this happen.
Thank you for the genius.
Bravery and patriotism of the judge should
get a medal.
No evidence whatsoever of any of that.
Trump also tweeting, Many Trump votes were
rounded to Biden.
The highly respected Michigan judge released
this epic report.
True, all over the country, this fake election
can no longer stand.
Get moving.
Republicans big swing state win.
Seventy five million votes.
That is also a completely baseless claim which
was flagged by Twitter as such.
So the good news is we're getting closer,
guys.
It's not that much longer and Trump will be
gone.
And a major step yesterday with Joe Biden
becoming a president elect with three hundred
and six electoral votes cast in their respective
state houses for president elect Joe Biden.
And in the midst of all of this, as if it
wasn't an insane enough day already, Attorney
General William Barr has resigned.
Let's discuss that next.